bonsoir il est 18 heures si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur tv fil 78 pour
le 7 8 ans ce 16 janvier nouvelle
édition voici dès à présent les titres
les sujets qui seront développées ce
soir en images le hêtre développement du
livre numérique sur ce plateau et ricard
d'un libraire ancien président d'une
commission numérique pour le syndicat la
des libraires nous verrons aussi que ce
marché intéresse les institutionnels le
conseil général a mis à disposition des
bibliothèques du département 45 liseuse
un tramway va rejoindre vélizy dans les
yvelines à châtillon dans les
hauts-de-seine une liaison interbanlieue
de 14 kilomètres marquée par un tunnel
long de 1,6 km le premier tour de roue
est prévue en mars 2013 la machine vient
d'être présenté et elle s'appelle
nolwenn la musique adoucit les moeurs
dit-on en tout cas pour la sncf c'est
une évidence l'entreprise publique et
installer un piano en garde
versailles-chantiers accessible aux
voyageurs mélomanes c'est la deuxième
expérience de ce type mené en ile de
france
et puis un cours de cuisine japonaise
proposé à guyancourt pour savoir comment
bien préparer sushis et autres maquis ce
sera tout à l'heure nous en parlerons à
lors du rendez vous culture sur cette
antenne avec johanna soudry dans une
vingtaine de minutes dans l'actualité
les suites de l'annoncé par renault hier
de la suppression de 7500 postes en
france d'ici à 2016 14% des effectifs au
niveau national cinq mille 500
suppressions seraient des départs dits
naturels les autres des départs
accompagné en ligne avec nous pour
ouvrir cette édition du 7 8 christophe
chollet bonsoir est délégué sud au
technocentre renault à guyancourt déjà
votre votre sentiment quelle était
l'ambiance aujourd'hui au technocentre
renault ont écouté l'ambiance c'était
quand même un choc ce matin en apprenant
les nouvelles bières fait les frais sans
suppressions d'emplois en plus on
apprend que sur sept mille façons
suppression et on a deux mille programmé
à l'ingénierie en sous forme de les
délocalisations d'hier vers les centres
indiens houmas donc
même si en apparence tout tout à l'air
paisible dans les industries fait le
champion et le délai sera assez court
puisque en deux ans cette suppression de
postes devront être effectives vous vous
attendiez une telle annonce
d'une certaine manière on c'est pour ça
qu'on parle de manipulation doit de
succès que la direction profite quand
même de la dégradation qui à laquelle a
mis en place elle-même de dégradation
des ventes qui sont des simplement à une
gamme qui a pas été suffisamment
renouveler prioritairement renouvelée
par rapport aux investissements qui ont
été consentis sur dacia
et comme en fait l'international et le
moteur de croissance de renault
maintenant en fait la nouvelle capacité
qu'ont été créés aux quatre coins du
monde ont pris le pas sur sur les young
qui sont maintenant engagés quoi et
aujourd'hui vous appeler à la
mobilisation ce matin déjà vous avez
commencé ajustements à mobiliser vos
différents collègues sur le technocentre
et demain matin encore absolument y aura
un rassemblement demain au technocentre
à 10 heures donc on veut mobiliser et
coordonner la mobilisation sur surtout
les filles chez toi le les ingénieries
ont comme les villes de fabrication pour
montrer que la pilule et il y aura une
prochaine réunion de concertation
officielle n'a cette fois ci ce sera le
22 janvier que va t-il se passait lors
de cette réunion avec justement les
représentants de renault
alors on fait toujours a fait difficile
de savoir que
de temps en temps la direction revient
un petit peu sur ce qu'elle a à dire a
expliqué elle traîne un petit peu en
longueur sur ces mesures de temps en
temps elle accélère en donnant des
détails ou même en s'adressant
directement aux médias comme on l'a fait
hier en fin d'après midi
cette façon les discussions continuent
et voilà et vous restez vigilants
nouvelle mobilisation dès demain merci
christophe delaine délégué sud au
technocentre renault de guyancourt
une nouvelle mobilisation au
technocentre programmée dès ce jeudi
nous en parlerons bien sûr au cours de
nos prochaines éditions
c'est l'avenir du livre qui va nous
intéresser à présent avec vous héritez
d'un an auparavant on va juste faire un
petit détour par vélizy on part pour
vélizy ou bientôt la ville sera relié à
châtillon par un tramway une liaison
interbanlieue de 14km valérie auribeau
et le diwan pour les explications
le tunnelier s'appellera nolwenn le 10
janvier le tunnel qui abritera le futur
tramway t6 reliant châtillon dans les
hauts-de-seine à viroflay dans les
yvelines a été baptisé le prénom choisi
n'est pas un hasard c'est celui d'une
jeune vie rohff les hyènes lauréate d'un
concours d'écriture basé sur le tunnel
du thé 6 est présente pour l'occasion un
projet important pour le département
n'oublions pas le pôle d'emplois que
constitue vélizy c'est donc à la fois
par ses industries ses centres
commerciaux sont qu'un endroit où on
vient où on va il est donc un lieu de
passage important et il convenait de le
desservir
confortablement le t6 reliera les hauts
de seine et les yvelines en 40 minutes
cette liaison interbanlieue de 14
kilomètres desservira six communes du 92
et deux dans le 78 facilitant ainsi les
déplacements de près de cent cinquante
mille visages et les conseils généraux
des deux départements assurent la
construction de l'infrastructure la ratp
elle sera à la tête du système de
transport les 384 millions d'euros du
projet final sont répartis entre la
région ile de france qui finance à
hauteur de 50% soit 190 millions d'euros
le conseil général des hauts-de-seine à
hauteur de 20% soit 76 millions d'euros
le conseil général des yvelines lui à
hauteur de 13%
soit 52 millions d'euros l'état à
hauteur de 16 % et 61 millions d'euros
et la ratp 1 % soit 3 millions d'euros
le projet sera mise en service dès 2014
pour la section deux surfaces et 2015
pour la totalité de la ligne la ligne en
souterrain pour un an de plus parce que
c'est plus compliqué de faire le travail
en effet le département souhaite
respecter les zones boisées et les zones
d'habitation la construction progresse
de 2 100 m par mois et devrait parvenir
à son terminus de la station viroflay
rive droite fin 2013
et puis l'actualité c'est aussi du sport
c'est officiel depuis la fin de cet
après-midi le tour de france passera par
saint quentin en yvelines ce sera la
dernière étape de cette 100e édition là
aussi bien évidemment nous en parlons
dans nos prochains journaux sur tv fil
pour parler du livre papier du livre
numérique également je reçois donc et
ricard d'un libraire le président
également de la commission numérique
ailières syndicat des libraires français
en 2008 vous avez publié justement un
compte-rendu accueillir le numérique
avec un point d'interrogation
une mutation pour le commerce du livre
on en reviendra reviendra aussi sur ses
différentes conclusions que vous aviez
fait à l'époque pour l'instant un
chiffre pour débuter cette séquence 2% 2
2% en france 1 à 2% du livre a basculé
sur le numérique c'est finalement assez
peu est ce que pour l'instant les
libraires n'ont pas l'impression de
créer un petit peu au loup où ils ont
été si lorient c'est un petit peu le
sentiment je crois que tout le monde est
dans cette position où les éditeurs tout
le monde sait que il va y avoir des
changements
tout le monde s'y prépare se pose des
questions parce qu'il y en a énormément
sur les modèles économiques sur les
droits d'auteur sur les questions de
conservation
beaucoup de questions pour l'instant
c'est un marché en devenir
c'est un marché en devenir pourtant par
exemple pour la musique c'est aller
beaucoup plus vite pour le lier donnons
le livre numérique pen peut-être plus à
s'installer non le livre l'écrit
numérique progresse énormément mais il
ya une différence entre le
téléchargement payant et bien sûr le
téléchargement livres gratuits et là
vous avez l'exemple de ce qui se passe
aux etats-unis où évidemment le
téléchargement et on le voit très bien
des coups on quitte les fêtes
au début du mois de janvier on a
énormément de téléchargement mais pour
une majorité des textes gratuits ou des
textes tellement aux droits libres de
droit et encore une enquête qui a été
publié d'ailleurs au cours de la journée
46 % des jeunes américains qui sont
séduits vraiment séduit par ce livre
numérique par rapport au papier
donc effectivement marché en devenir
sans doute également en france ça va
certainement progresser surtout que au
moment des fêtes de fin d'année
tablettes et autres liseuses se sont
particulièrement bien vendus c'était un
cadeau plutôt recherchée est ce que vous
l'avez ressenti dans vos votes
justement cette année sur les périodes
de flash pas d'accord avec vous et tout
ce que je lis est en contradiction avec
ce que vous dites c'est à dire qu en
effet les liseuses se sont nettement
moins bien vendu les mecs comme les
tablettes a pris le dessus et largement
dessus ça veut donc dire que le modèle
uniquement livre des liseuses étant
plutôt en stagnant ou parce que les
tables maison on peut faire beaucoup
plus de choses
voilà mais c'est la question aussi du
livre et de l'écrit et la place de
l'écrit et du livre dans la société donc
c'est pas simplement le numérique pour
les numériques le numérique on y passait
déjà depuis très très longtemps sur un
certain nombre de secteurs est
aujourd'hui dans vos ventes
comment se sont passées ces fêtes de fin
d'année est ce que le livre c'est moins
bien vendu le livre papier le livre
papier on a une baisse de chiffre
d'affaires au niveau des librairies je
pense que c'est un constat qui se fait
au niveau national mais enfin il ya une
morosité morosité qui s'est fait qu'on a
trouvé au mois de décembre sur les fêtes
nous ne vendons pas de tablettes et des
liseuses haut niveau en librairie pour
l'instant on est en train d'étudier un
produit projet mutualisé entre les
libraires mais pour l'instant nous nous
arc bouton et nous regardons comment
vendre du texte numérique à nos clients
qui sont équipés déjà on va voir
justement comment vous allez aborder ces
prochaines années peut-être parler
justement de de cet aspect vous avez dit
pour l'instant vous ne vendez pas de
liseuses oui parce qu'on ait fait
l'elysée ça reste en projet pourquoi pas
de développer une tablette ou en tout
cas s'associe avec un constructeur
l'instant il ya un certain nombre de
choses vous savez que les yeux c'est pas
une question facile que il ya beaucoup
de liseuses qui sont propriétaires
savaient donc dire qu'un effet quand
vous vous mettez avec amazon sur kindle
ou lorsque vous vous mettez avec un
apple vous êtes dans un site
propriétaire
donc dire que vous votre fournisseur
d'accès vos achats obligatoirement vont
passer par amazon par par apple ou autre
et ça c'est évidemment un problème que
les gens ne réalisent pas très bien
c'est comme si on se mettait poings et
pieds liés avec un seul fournisseur
effectivement ensuite pour le choix mais
ne serait ce que pour les prix également
là forcément c'est beaucoup plus limité
pour faire jouer ne serait-ce que la
concurrence vous avez vous possédez déjà
une liseuse ou une tablette
oui totalité ils ont deux supports
numériques tout à fait tout à fait mais
sur la concurrence alors il faudrait
peut-être discuter de ce qu'est la
concurrence parce qu'en fait il n'y a
pas de concurrence au niveau du prix
puisque rappelons nous que même sur le
livre numérique soit les textes
numériques qui sont vendus c'est un prix
imposé et avec une tva réduite qui est
des dessus donc il n'y a pas deux fois
de lui rien il ya dit quelquefois des
moyens de concours de contourner un
petit peu ces dispositions légales
lorsqu'on achète quand on est fidèles on
a quelques pourcentages de réduction sur
les livres dans certaines enseignes par
exemple le livre papier non pour le
livre papier en effet une possibilité de
remises 5%
donc la question elle est plutôt au
niveau de l'interopérabilité entre les
différentes plateformes qui fournissent
et c'est ça qui est compliqué à faire
comprendre aux gens c'est qu'aujourd'hui
vous allez dans une librairie vous avez
la possibilité d'avoir un choix d'à peu
près un million cent mille vivent 700000
disponibles 6000 éditeurs tout passe par
la librairie alors qu'aujourd'hui dans
le numérique vous avez un ensemble de
plateformes et de contrats qui font
qu'aujourd'hui quand vous achetez dans
sur une plateforme vous ne pouvez pas
l'utiliser ailleurs c'est très compliqué
vous possédez malgré tout une mise à
jour tablettes et aux liseuses please
elles vont adeptes de ces livres
numériques nous sommes allés poser la
question aujourd'hui dans les rues de
saint quentin en yvelines parce que je
suis pas tout dit et puis parce que moi
j'aime bien avoir un bouquin dans la
main avec les pages etc
quand je dis j ai des livres en un mot
c'est ça fait moins mal aux yeux en
général je suis souvent sur sur mon
écran effectivement ou
sur ma tablette ou non du tout parce que
j'aime bien toucher mon papier quand je
lis un livre et on est allé sur l'écran
toute la journée donc on n'a pas trop
envie de re passer du temps sur l'écran
lors du tour parce que
ça me dépasse et j'ai pas d'expérience
parce que j'ai grandi j'ai vu toute
l'évolution de l'informatique et que le
livre numérique me semble une évidence
pour les générations futures une
rapidité un gain de place pour stocker
une facilité de de connaissances malgré
tout les gens restent attachés au papier
au livre papier d'ailleurs on l'a
entendu c'est normal je préfère un livre
normal un livre normal c'est un livre
papier
ça fait plaisir pour un libraire mais je
crois qu'il faut regarder aussi qu est
ce qu est ce qui se vend au niveau du
numérique et c'est ça qui est assez
intéressant et juste avant de venir je
me suis connecté sur un rapport qui ce
qui ce qui vient des états unis qui
montre très clairement que deux livres
numériques sur trois qui sont achetés
sont ce qu'on appelle des livres
jetables ça veut dire des livres
bibliothèque de garou amouroux sexe
justement peut-être cité un titre et un
livre qui s'est bien vendu c'est à 50
nuance me grey goose trilogie plutôt
érotique le premier et d'érotisme de
moment c'est ça s'est plutôt bien vendu
parce que par exemple le premier tome en
france s'est vendu 25 mille exemplaires
en numérique 870000 en papier aux etats
unis les ebooks représente la moitié des
ventes totales pour ce team oui au
niveau mondial je reconnais à 34
millions de titres pour ceux de
l'exemplaire vendu pour ce titre mais je
crois que derrière c'est un ouvrier les
chiffes mais il ya un problème culturel
qui est de dire quelle est la nature des
livres qu'on va produire s'est apprécié
en fait la majorité des gens ne lisent
que des bibliothèques de guerre des
livres revues érotiques et autres on
sent bien que la production va
s'orienter vers ça ça veut donc dire que
les conditions de création de la culture
de demain des livres de la littérature
isation culturel exactement c'est le
risque que l'on court et les études
montrent que des faits cet aspect est
peu pris en compte
j'aurais juste quand même aborder ce
point là pour l'instant l'émigré résiste
bien vous réussissez réussissait à
rester en tout cas ouvert c'est pas le
cadre des concurrents mais des grandes
enseignes par exemple virgin qui s'était
installé à 50 ans neeve et c'est au
niveau national mais l'enseigne
rencontrent de grandes difficultés
on aurait pu penser que c'était vers
jean qui aurait pu faire disparaître vos
librairies par exemple là vous allez
rester sans doute le verdict à
disparaître
quel regard vous avez sur les situations
la situation rencontrée par cette grande
enseigne culturelle triste d'abord c'est
une c'est toujours triste de voir une
une comme ça surtout qu'à 1000 salariés
quand même au niveau de l'ensemble des
26 ou 28 magasins virgin donc que triste
savoir si la librairie va résister il ya
beaucoup de fermetures de librairies qui
sont liés à des problèmes donc nous on
est confronté comme aux pavés du canal
on est confronté à des problèmes de
loyer et d'évolution de loyer en
centre-ville ou là le propriétaire nous
mène plutôt mal donc dont on a quand
même une baisse de chiffre d'affaires
une baisse de l'activité des secteurs
entiers sont déjà passés au numérique
je pense aux droits à l'universitaire
aux sciences humaines c'est un problème
nous n'arrivons pas à compenser la perte
de chiffre d'affaires qui se fait dans
tous ces secteurs là tu dans les
secteurs de dictionnaires encyclopédies
ou les guides de voyage on voit bien que
le numérique gps ou autre a pris le
dessus c'est pas simplement une question
de liseuses ou de tablettes
quelles pistes mais aussi les
smartphones quelles pistes vous explorez
justement aujourd'hui pour pouvoir
continuer à vendre du livre ventes de
livres numériques par exemple est
envisageable sous quelle forme dans
votre wii on vendra des livres
numériques actuellement on a le projet à
la librairie de mettre en place un écran
tactile qui te permettra d'accéder à
notre site web www point fr qui permet
aux gens de voir d'abord ce qui existe
dans l'édition française il ya quand
même un million cent mille titres peu
près 700 milles disponibles nous nous
avons à peu près 45 mille titres dans la
librairie
donc les gens pourront voir ce que nous
avons et en même temps de façon tactile
et pour pouvoir si cette façon numérique
et à ce moment là où télécharger ou se
faire prendre des liens donner un lien
pour pouvoir télécharger chez eux le
texte
mais ce n'est pas aussi simple que ça
parce que on parlait tout à l'heure des
sites ou des outils propriétaires
aujourd'hui jusqu'à relativement peu
lorsque vous chargez un texte sur votre
smartphone ou sur une tablette vous ne
pouviez pas le prêter à votre voisin
vous pouvez pas le traiter à votre soeur
vous pourriez pas le transférer sur
autre chose
ces questions de protection de ceux
qu'on appelle les drm 1 est un problème
important qu'il y ait également à des
problèmes de droits d'auteurs et de
protection de l'oeuvre culturelle
problèmes rencontrés par la musique
aussi par les vidéos exactement ces
dernières années même si aujourd'hui on
se concentre sur le livre on quitte ce
plateau pendant quelques instants
on part donc de guyancourt pour se
rendre du côté des clayes-sous-bois
auprès d'une autre enseigne
distribution de produits culturels et
ont fait un point qu'ils ont des
tablettes qui vend aussi des tablettes
justement on va faire le point sur ses
ventes de tablettes voir comment dans ce
magasin se sont passées les fêtes de fin
d'année il est désormais difficile d'y
échapper
la lecture numérique investi les
magasins depuis sa mise sur le marché en
mais les yvelinois ont encore du mal à
lire du virtuel je me suis pas habitué
j'essaye de me forcer à m'habituer
mais zéro ça j'arrive pas moi quand je
lis mph du papier fois un bouquin qui me
plaît c'est d'avoir l'objet en main et
puis j'aime l'odeur du papier et voilà
donc je retrouve pas dans ça dans les
tablettes même si je trouve ça très
intéressant de pouvoir stocker beaucoup
d'informations sur un seul objet léger
portatif dans ce magasin des
clayes-sous-bois les liseuses de livres
numériques ont été mises en rayon il ya
quelques mois et les ventes ont déjà
décollé avec ses tablettes vous n'êtes
plus obligé de transporter votre
bibliothèque quand vous partez en
vacances
la liseuse pouvant stocker plusieurs
milliers d'ouvragés des produits de
consommation
selon un baromètre d'opinionway de
novembre 2012 le nombre d'électeurs en
france a plus que doublé en six mois et
représentent désormais 14% des 15 ans et
plus pourtant le marché français du
livre numérique estimé à 20 millions
d'euros est noyée dans les 4 milliards
d'euros de la forme papier
malgré des oeuvres moins coûteuse les
collecteurs pour obtenir vos livres
favoris il vous faudra débourser entre
80 et 150 euros
alors et rijkaard inquiète en plateau a
aussi des chiffres parce que vous êtes
très documenté sur ce sujet des livres
et vous me disais que la croissance
était moins important que cette année
par ex pareil toujours les statistiques
qui sont extrêmement récente ce sont des
statistiques qui prouvent qu en effet le
taux de croissance d'évolution de
croissance de la vente en effet des
tablettes et surtout des liseuses et
moindres c'est vrai que c'est toujours
une progression spectaculaire puisqu'on
est à 34 % mais on est largement en
dessous de l'évolution qui s'est faite
l'année dernière qui était à plus de
100%
le 12 décembre dernier un colloque a été
organisé notamment par livres hebdo et
il s'y disait que le livre numérique
c'était surtout pour les gros lecteurs
ont confirmé oui je crois que là vous
l'avez vu dans le reportage c'est vrai
que lorsque vous partez en vacances et
que vous pouvez avoir les 300 bouquin
que vous voulez très bien comment ils
pas 300 aucun pendant c'est exactement
ça que j'allais vous dire c'est un peu
le problème de la musique quand vous
aviez
ipad ou iphone pardon avec 303 milles
morceaux de musique les trois ça sert
d'avoir trois cents 300 titres que vous
n'allez pas lire je veux dire c'est
vraiment cette besoin de posséder au
lieu de livres alors puisque nous
parlons en du livre numérique de son
développement il n'y a pas que les
grandes enseignes qui s'y intéressent le
conseil général des yvelines vient de
mettre à disposition des bibliothèques
qui le souhaitent 45 liseuse
expérimentations menées à d'abord dans à
six communes aujourd'hui dans huit
autres a toujours à la demande des
professionnels du secteur vous voyez la
cérémonie de remise de ces liseuses
c'était il ya quelques jours dans le
département des yvelines
une opération qui ont un coût jugé
raisonnable par le département 4500
euros pour l'achat des liseuses 1000
euros pour le chargement complet des
livres on va écouter pierre lequiller
conseiller général qui s'occupe de ce
dossier
c'est un instrument qui est quand même
très confortable très très agréable à
utiliser et
nous avons fait une première expérience
avec six comme si bibliothèque est là
aujourd'hui nous poursuivons cette
expérience parce que les résultats de la
première ont été extrêmement apprécié à
la fois par les bibliothécaires et par
les lecteurs lille disparaître à jamais
eu
mais en même temps il faut accompagner
la modernité il faut utiliser
l'évolution de la science les
possibilités formidables qu'elle offre
et
et cela dit yao clean craintes
bibliothèque heures à noter que cette
expérimentation sera reconduite en
septembre 2013 avec huit autres communes
dont chevreuse et rochefort en yvelines
et saint quentin en yvelines au milieu
de tout ça me direz vous les
médiathèques dépendent de la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin
elle nous avons rencontré à catherine
villanova il s'occupe de ce dossier les
responsables de la médiathèque de
voisins-le-bretonneux alors dans les
médiathèques de saint quentin on essaie
de te prendre le virage du numérique
comme on dit
donc on a déjà depuis plusieurs années
des abonnements numériques et adepte des
abonnements à des revues
les gens peuvent consulter ici sur les
postes quelques abonnements qui peuvent
consulter aussi de chez eux des livres
numériques récent qui qu'on achète chez
numilog que les gens peuvent consulter
soit ici soit ce soit chez eux depuis le
début janvier
on a souhaité mettre en place aussi des
prêts de liseuses donc les liseuses
permettent sur un fort avec un format
très pratique on peut le mettre dans sa
poche d'avoir accès à plusieurs
centaines de livres dont danse est ce
petit format pour l'instant donc on en
prête
il ya une part médiathèque y en a plus
qui vont être achetés dans les mois qui
viennent et pour l'instant il ya
uniquement des livres gratuits dessus
mais le projet est bien sûr de mettre
aussi des livres récents qui peuvent
intéresser davantage les lecteurs il
faut que les bibliothèques apprennent ce
virage du numérique et montre que et un
livre numérique un roman numérique c'est
comme un livre normal en fait c'est le
l'important c'est le contenu qui soit
sur papier où qu'ils soient sur une
liseuse
c'est la même chose en fait il faut
regarder ce qui se passe aux etats unis
puisque ils sont toujours très en avance
en fait là bas
les best-sellers par exemple est vendu
autant en numérique
quant au papier alors qu'en france il ya
5 % des ventes qui sont en numérique là
bas certains livres c'est 50%
donc là bas en fait ce sont surtout des
gros lecteurs qui utilisent les liseuses
beaucoup de lectrices de lectrices qui
lisent des romans sentimentaux et des
best-sellers donc les gros lecteurs sont
vraiment intéressés puisque on peut
partir en vacances avec une liseuse qui
doit peser 200 grammes et avec 500
livres à l'intérieur donc c'est ça va
surtout intéresser ses lecteurs là dans
l'immédiat et il savait surtout être le
développement des tablettes qui va
changer les choses mais les livres le
livre encore quand même eu quelques
quelques années de vie devant lui et
puis des ipad aussi devraient être
installés dans ces différentes
médiathèques pour l'instant vous l'avez
compris lui liseuse qui sont en prêt à
travers les huit médiathèque de saint
quentin en yvelines et ricardo en tant
que libraire votre regard sur l'arrivée
des liseuses dans ses différentes
médiathèques sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines
non mais je veux dire c'est toujours
suivre la mode mais je trouvais quand
même rappeler que le rôle des
bibliothèques d'abord c'est la
conservation des documents et la
conservation du livre et c'est pour ça
que je vais garder comme les y est je
cherchais un défait de ses parties les
joueurs savent ce que ceux ci on aurait
pu faire âge - disquette c'est une vraie
tenue méric qui aujourd'hui est
illisible
il n'y a plus rien pour lui lire or
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup de
bibliothèques et de bibliothèques
publiques ont confié à du privé ont
confié un gros opérateur le soin de
numériser leurs textes
donc est ce qu'on peut faire confiance
au privé qui est quand même cas pour
finalité le business l'argent et le
profit pour entretenir et garder notre
patrimoine culturel dans le temps donc
je crois qu'il faut quand même se
rappeler que d'abord les bibliothèques
c'est la conservation des documents dans
le temps et que aujourd'hui on ne peut
plus lire cela qu'en sera-t-il dans 20
ans et juste pour conclure une dernière
question puisque ça a été confirmé vous
l'avais dit avant le début de l'émission
dans l'après midi il y aura un prix
numérique qui sera développée entre vos
librairies les libraires et puis
également
les médiathèques de 50 ans voilà c'est à
dire que l'effet
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à travers le
réseau des médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et les
librairies pavé nous nous sommes portés
candidats pour tester le pré numérique
en bibliothèque
c'est un projet qui est développé par
l'interprofession et par dilicom donc
des éditeurs des distributeurs et des
libraires et ce projet sera présenté
finalisé au sein au salon du livre de
paris vers le 20 mai mars par de gaulle
la merci à vous aurez l'occasion de
revenir pour nous en parler merci à
l'écart d'un libraire sur saint quentin
en yvelines le livre numérique qui
progresse mais qui ne représentent
aujourd'hui encore que peu près entre 1
et 2% du marché le livre papier pour
l'instant on va dire se porte bien en
tout cas il survit